the Germany squad are recovering from
their grueling quarter-final against
France Melanie Bellingham Baudette Pater
both played in that match and soon
they'll be preparing for the semi-final
but first they're getting a
well-deserved break from full intensity
training stankin'-ass via relative
because I think we'll have relatively
limited training and try to get our
strength by eating and sleeping a lot
and getting some treatment I think in
four days time we'll be back to full
strength yeah by falak often the team
will have to be prepared for their next
opponents they'll come up against
another tournament favorite in the form
of the USA and the players know it'll be
a tough game this video doesn't fight
off over here it'll be another fight
against a team at our level will have to
beat them to reach the final and that's
not an easy task so we're focusing
everything on the USA its sheer that's
enough was on mr. let's do [ __ ] it's the
last step towards our goal so it's easy
to get motivated and look forward to the
game that goal of reaching the final is
so close the players can almost touch it
but after the dramatic penalties win
over France they won't be taking
anything for granted